um jadavian clowney seems like he's
forgotten
early in free agency every year and then
he pops up with some sort of a splash
late two years ago it was that trade
when he was franchise tag to seattle
last year he was a late
training camp
no preseason but close to the start of
the regular season edition by the titans
now
visited the cleveland browns left
without a deal how about the browns with
miles garrett good god on one side and
jadavian clowning moving around wherever
you want to put him they've had attack
mckinley but he's not jadav and clowny
you know clown he's healthy yeah
clowney's got to be healthy that's
that's the the lure has got to be you're
watching film of clowney saying my god
but but then you got to accept the fact
that
he's going to go stretches
of the season and not be at 100
exactly i think that's exactly the
problem i think it's another case here
too where a guy walks into a building
and he realizes the market's not
anything what he was expecting it to be
and it's it's you know even though i i'm
judy and connie i've got to think he's
about a little realistic about hey i do
have a really big time injury history
you know even in seattle two years ago
where he did a lot of good things
man i mean
it still was a lot of weeks of being
banged up hurt not being able to play
that year right i mean there was really
only a handful of like really special
games or moments all together so with
what we've seen
the lack of money given to talented in
their prime type of players who have no
injury right now in the nfl
again i think that that's one of those
where it just it pops out where he there
he's probably like what that's all
you're gonna offer me hold on a second
here he would be awesome coming off the
edge opposite of miles garrett again hey
there's another team running the seattle
scheme they're not interested in richard
sherman either joe woods and all that he
came from the 49ers but you know clowney
again is like you said when healthy
there's a difference maker coming off
the edge he's special that way but i
just can't imagine anybody giving him
big money uh in a year like this
i know it is just amazing to think of
what he can do when he's at his best i
still think about that monday night game
against the 49ers right when he was with
the seahawks that that was it was
amazing to force performance but the
enemy was hurt last week right he
started to develop a sports hernia right
in the aftermath of that game or during
that game i think he said at one point
he felt it for the first time
during that game and it's unfortunate he
was the first overall pick in the draft
and he was well compensated but not like
the first overall pick used to be before
they put in the rookie wage scale he
never got a big second contract and it's
not like he's we're not we're not saying
the guy's going hungry it's just a shame
that he hasn't gotten the financial
compensation that a guy with his talent
and ability
deserves but the problem is when you
have these health questions it's hard to
get a long-term deal he's he we've said
this before he's perpetually going to be
a one-year deal guy for the rest of his
career i think so most likely until he
could show like oh wait he's definitely
healthy he played 16 games last year
then you might see him get a two or
three-year deal to go along with that
but mike i mean you're spot on one it
stinks you know i i do i i hear you i
feel for you i mean this guy i mean feel
for him that way he's special and he's
way better than people even realize as
we've talked about before too because
when he is healthy he is another one of
those guys that's the king of the f to
play up yeah he might not get 12 and 15
sacks a year but he's one of those guys
you're turning on the film and you go
whoa
run play minus three yards wait uh whoa
that was clowning he messed that play up
oh quarterback throws the ball out of
bounds oh that was clowney who got in
there made the quarterback have to throw
the ball away there's just so many plays
like that he's got incredible play
strength for a guy his size he's a
pound guy that has the strength of a 310
pound guy and then has the speed of a
guy who's 240 pounds it's just really
really rare total freaking nature but
the injury bug has got him and that's
going to scare a lot of teams in this
year like this and the browns come on
now the browns are close
they're close
they need to get somebody on the other
side of miles gary that they can depend
on to play the whole year i mean they're
they're kind of like you look at their
team and you start to go oh window
you're in the window here and they could
do something special i'm excited to see
what that next move will be to get them
another pass rusher
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports